you want to see it i would love to see
it national academy of recording arts
and sciences
lifetime achievement award 2021 selena
wow isn't it awesome it's amazing
[Music]
i want to start with a quote that i know
is very meaningful to you
and to selena fans around the world the
goal
isn't to live forever but to create
something
that will that quote is being honored
in the most beautiful way during the
grammy awards on sunday if your sister
selena
is the recipient of the lifetime
achievement award
it meant awesome what was your reaction
to that
mind-blowing um i i believe i even got a
little teary-eyed on that
there's a lot of video out there and
footage of selena when she talks about
how excited she was to win the grammy
and i was so um honored to be able to be
with her and chris and bill and i were
there um
whenever she won the award and how
amazing she looked
on that night and and then now we're
we're 25 years later and
who would have ever thought and that she
would be honored with this lifetime
achievement award and
i think it's also for me um i'm very
proud and i know she would be also in
regards to
the fact that we are mexicanos
ameriganos you know we're mexican
americans and
this is happening so it's huge it's it's
really huge for so many you know for a
different couple of reasons
more importantly the fact that her
career and her life
is still being celebrated so many years
later as it should be
as it should be i agree you touched on
the fact that selena is no stranger to
the grammy awards in 1994 she took home
the award for best
mexican american album for selena live
can you take me back to that 1994
grammys awards ceremony what do you
remember what were those conversations
you were having with her that night
she was really excited about taking her
camera in she has a little
polaroid one that kind of you uh not the
polar word but the kind of you the throw
away
yeah yeah and they didn't let her come
in with it so she was pretty bummed out
about that because she wanted to take
pictures with everyone
and she was in that white dress it was
all blue just
amazing sounded amazing to take in that
experience i'll never forget that night
for sure
but i will share a really cool part
about that night
we're leaving um radio city city music
hall in new york
and i remember we were crossing the
street and
people started chanting your name like
selena oh my gosh
that's lena and selena looked at me are
they saying my name
you know and then i turn around go yeah
we turned around like a little group of
people over
on the side that we were leaving you
know and they were like hey
like that and just saying hi to her and
she was like oh my god and she waved she
was wow they know me here
what is the quintanilla family plan are
you flying to la are you coming to the
grammys no
it's not a social gathering type of
thing and that's the reason why they
um sent over the award you want to see
it i would love to see it
yet national academy of recording arts
and sciences lifetime achievement award
2021
selena wow isn't it awesome
it's amazing it actually it's it's
sitting here in her museum
right next to her grammy wow that is so
special suzette
it is is there a quintania family
viewing party going down are you all
going to be huddled together on one
couch
enjoying the moment um no
i think we are still kind of keeping my
parents safe
but we'll definitely be watching and
definitely i hope everybody
else will be as well i'm looking forward
to it i would love to give you the
opportunity right now
here on entertainment tonight to just
kind of look in the camera you can say
anything you'd like to say to the
grammys or to the fans who have helped
get selena to this place
um like always it's nothing but mad love
for
everyone that continues to love and
honor my sister
um it's just i'm very proud to be a part
of
this family i'm very proud to be a part
of
um my band los dinos you know our band
was incredible
joe pete to ricky chris um
don and freddie and my brother and of
course my beautiful
sister selena um they're an art uh how
could i forget art
or percussionist music is powerful and
for it to transcend
over 25 years and still being played
you know it's pretty incredible and i'm
very honored to be a part of all of it
and i know if selena was here she would
have said the same thing
[Music]
i know this is such a difficult question
but if you had to pinpoint
one moment that you think best
defines selena's career what would that
moment be
i would have to say the grammys when she
won the grammy for the live album
and being recognized at this level
you know for a mexican-american
band that played the honor music in a
realm of
you know latin music which is this big
i've always explained
latin the latin music is about this big
and the honey music is like that little
bitty speck right there
and um i think that that probably for me
would be the moment where it was like
you know what
we're not so crazy it can happen of
course your parents your father
especially really included in your
musical journey your mom
a pillar of strength and really there
for you as a family
what do they think of this big lifetime
achievement award
oh my dad and my mother i mean my
brother we're all honored i mean
um this is pretty i mean it's huge this
is really huge huge honor
the fact that it's 25 years later it
that's powerful you know that's a
powerful message
of where selena is um and she's very
much alive in everyone's
hearts i know as we saw in the
selena the series the netflix series yes
mr q
mr q is oftentimes not very impressed
i just heard them ambassador they're
playing it on the radio so
lots of bands have one hit where's your
next one was this award cool enough
to impress him yes most definitely
i think you know what dj to be honest
with you um
if you also in the movie you know that
edward james almost and also now the
netflix series
if you look at both of them after a gig
you know there'd be a soul
concert or they'd be super packed you
know at a venue and
we would you know how do we do and he'd
be like yeah y'all did okay you know he
would never give us
oh you know that praise and i think that
in a
in a way that really drove us even more
to um to be better i think that was a
driving force that he kind of was
mind tricking us in some way to be able
to to push us
more you know and uh and it worked
i know your brother has publicly called
winning this grammy lifetime achievement
award
a little bittersweet does it feel that
way for you
i mean everything is bittersweet you
know
due to the fact that she's no longer
here and she
should be here she should be here
talking to you deidra and me on the you
know
right here next to her and but it's not
that way
so you know i i i try to focus on
the beauty that she has left behind um
it's what helps me
deal with her not being here we live in
a time also where i have
the luxury of going online deidre and i
can look at her
you know most people that live lows
loved ones they don't have that
somebody sent me something recently
about maybe a month ago and she's doing
the interview and she said something
like
oh hey before i go i i oh i can't
believe i didn't knew you i didn't i
didn't do it uh
i didn't give love to my sister hey
suzette you know and then she starts
talking about that and about her
nickname
she called me buffy and then they start
laughing and making fun about the [ __ ]
that what
buffy means and it's a kind of form of
getting you between us
and um see i have that and that makes me
happy it made me cry
when i came across it but it made me
feel good i just feel like you have to
really
focus on the good things that make you
feel great
and don't focus on the stuff that you
know
you cannot change this is how life is
and i've embraced
what my life is since you know it's
taken me many years to
be able to um come down this road am i
okay
no there's some bad days too dj you know
i'm not gonna lie but
for the most part i really try to focus
on the beauty um
of everything that i was able to share
with my sister with my family
with our amazing band and this right
here this
lifetime achievement award given to
selena
for a uh an amazing career that she left
behind
what would selena think of getting the
grammy lifetime achievement award
oh i think she would be over the moon i
think she would
um be very giddy about it and um
extremely happy and i think that this
ward i hope
that the younger generation the younger
latinas and the younger
overall everyone young you know they can
go back and they can look at this and
think you know wow you know
she's still doing it and she's not even
here and she's been gone for 25 years
and that's a powerful powerful message
and i hope that that resonates in our
youth
i really do
[Music]